en politique les symboles sont
essentiels arrivés en trains qui annick
jadot a visité besançon à vélo le député
européen figures d'europe écologie les
verts roule ici pour la candidate de son
parti
anne vignot premier tour adjointe
sortante en charge de l'environnement
l'ingénieur de recherche au cnrs
ambitionne de devenir maire de la
capitale comtoise pendant longtemps
c'était si t'aime pas les écolos casse
un vélo et maintenant c'est tous à vélo
tous écolos ce qui se passe à besançon
ce rassemblement très large des
écologistes de la gauche des citoyens
pour conquérir la ville pour exercer les
responsabilités pas pour accaparer le
pouvoir pour le rendre aux citoyens et
pour agir au service des bisontines et
des bisontins je trouve ça génial donc
l'épousé clan 102,7 du loup fo
totalement dédiés à des activités
culture sports loisirs à besançon anne
vignot est en effet à la tête d'une
union avec les socialistes et les
communistes notamment si yannick jadot
prom régulièrement une ligne ni gauche
ni droite pour europe ecologie les verts
la candidate bisontine assume clairement
son ancrage à gauche considèrent qu'une
société se doit de porter un soin tout à
fait particulier à ceux qui sont les
plus vulnérables et l'écologie
d'ailleurs et dans son fondement a
toujours eu cette attention particulière
est donc oui je suis une femme de gauche
parce que je ne conçois pas une société
qui ne soit pas pleinement solidaire à
gauche depuis 1953
dirigée aujourd'hui par un maire macro
nist besançon fait partie des villes
ardemment convoité par les écologistes
aux municipales